est-ce que vous avez le droit déjà de
publier ce lien non j'avais un fusil à
pompe avec moi en permanence j'avais été
au contact de l'un des traducteurs de
Poutine il est logique aussi d'avoir
peur
Richard Bolland a passé toute sa
carrière au service de renseignement
extérieur français il vient donc de
prendre sa retraite il publie ses
mémoires espions 44 ans à la DGSE une
précision tout de même c'est un pseudo
car il souhaite rester anonyme pour des
raisons de sécurité voici donc une
plongée inédite dans les coulisses de
l'espionnage français avec un ancien
agent déjà pour commencer comment est-ce
qu'on devient agent de la DGSE comment
est-ce que de votre côté vous êtes
retrouvé ici et aujourd'hui quel est le
parcours en général pour terminer à Jean
de la DGSE
dans mon cas un peu par hasard ça a été
le au niveau de mon père qui travaillait
depuis la Seconde Guerre mondiale comme
beaucoup de résistance il y avait
intégré le service
et donc moi à l'époque je savais pas
trop ce que je voulais faire en tout
état de cause il était hors de question
de travailler dans l'administration au
départ j'ai fait mon service militaire
j'étais pistolet évidemment puisque à
l'époque c'est hors de question de faire
son service militaire là où on habitait
à proximité il y avait un brassage entre
les différentes provinces et donc
pendant les 10 mois
c'était un travail administratif qui
était pas très très intéressant voilà
photos copie etc et puis après quand j'y
suis resté c'était aussi un travail mais
qui
dirigé plus vers le côté archives donc
c'est là que j'ai été infecté et ça me
plaisait beaucoup parce que il y avait
un côté historique c'est toujours aimé
l'histoire et donc là je me suis piqué
au jeu et j'ai essayé de progresser
justement dans ce domaine
d'archivistes avant de devenir du coup
agent véritablement agent ou à travers
les concours que j'ai passé
après je me suis retrouvé après sur le
terrain et notamment par le plus grand
des hasards sur une première affectation
clandestine ça veut dire des gens qui
sont déployés à l'étranger mais sous une
couverture
une véritable couverture qui n'est
absolument pas étatique parce que moi je
travaille dans le privé au titre d'une
société certes qui était à la main du
service mais qui travaillait dans
l'immobilier donc j'étais un agent
immobilier après quand je suis devenu
véritablement agent là j'étais sous
couverture diplomatique voilà là je
n'étais pas pour une entreprise ou quoi
que ce soit là c'était purement
diplomatique comme tous les agents des
services du monde entier ont une
couverture diplomatique avec un rôle
défini au sein d'une ambassade en
principe le seul l'ambassadeur est au
courant si l'agent n'est pas déclaré aux
autorités locales donc comme diplôme là
soit s'il y a un véritable partenariat
avec les services locaux là
effectivement tout le monde est au
courant de l'activité de l'agent
aujourd'hui si quelqu'un veut rejoindre
la DGSE en tant qu'agent comment on fait
alors il suffit de passer le concours et
maintenant la communication est assez
transparente puisqu'il y a un site pour
présenter les concours il y a également
même des rapports de jury qui sont
produits sur les sessions précédentes
les profils qui sont recherchés donc ça
peut aller de toutes sortes de
catégories de de catégories plus
modestes à celle d'un ingénieur
cryptographe ce que vous voulez il y a
aussi une voie de recrutement par sous
contrat parce qu'on a de plus en plus de
contractuels voilà ça c'est ce qui
concerne les civils voilà pour les
militaires ils sont déjà en affectation
régiment ils font une demande de
mutation quelles sont les compétences et
les qualités selon vos qui sont
nécessaires pour travailler la DGSE et
justement de travailler sur le terrain
en tant qu'agent de la DGSE c'est
surtout de ne pas sombrer dans la
paranoïa d'être quand même suffisamment
équilibré
parce que sinon ça devient extrêmement
difficile si on perd une capacité de
discernement ou si on en a pas du tout
voilà c'est de l'humain rien n'est écrit
vous avez une formation bien évidemment
qui vous permet de d'avoir quelques clés
mais sinon le rein c'est votre
personnalité c'est créativité réactivité
adaptation adaptabilité c'est c'est tout
ça voilà c'est une forme de sang-froid
aussi j'imagine pour être capable de
maîtriser n'importe quelle situation et
s'en sortir le mieux possible oui mais
il est logique aussi d'avoir peur parce
que quelqu'un qui n'a pas peur qui est
trop froid ça devient dangereux aussi il
a plus de perception avec la réalité des
événements et qui perd son côté humain
ça bien aussi donc la peur est aussi une
force d'une certaine façon c'est exact
il faut absolument que les gens aient
peur
après moi je suis toujours connu des
gens qui avaient peur et moi le premier
parce que vous retrouvez dans des
situations faudrait vraiment être un
animal à sang froid pour voilà sur la
peur quel est le moment vous avez
peut-être eu le plus peur dans votre
carrière en tant qu'agent sur le terrain
pour moi ça a été le génocide rwandais
enfin juste après avec toutes les
conséquences qui ont été déclenchées
après le génocide c'était effectivement
dans la ville là où j'étais la ville
était complètement assiégée et donc
j'avais un fusil à pompe avec moi en
permanence et dormir avec un fusil à
pompe c'est pas évident ça fait mal aux
côtes et vous demandez toujours si vous
pouvez pas faire une nuit complète c'est
pas possible et puis aussi de tout ce
cortège d'horreur notamment de gens
brûlés dans les pneus c'est
impressionnant c'est impressionnant et
c'est vraiment c'est choquant un des
éléments importants c'est cette
dimension d'information être sur le
terrain pour essayer de récupérer les
informations est-ce que vous l'expliquer
un peu en quoi ça consiste quel genre
d'information auprès de qui comment
est-ce qu'on recrute une source et
comment ça se passe d'abord par un
ciblage c'est d'ailleurs vous ciblez les
personnes qui vous intéressent dans un
domaine précis non ça peut être je sais
pas le renseignement militaire ça peut
être
politique au niveau d'un ministre d'une
secrétaire voilà donc cette personne une
fois que vous l'avez ciblée avec un
minimum d'environnement voilà qui est sa
vie qui elle fréquente etc donc vous
portez au comptable vous discutez avec
vous lui expliquez en gros pour quelle
raison vous êtes intéressé par des
échanges avec cette personne
sachant que vous êtes sur place vous
êtes diplomate entre guillemets donc là
en l'occurrence t'attache humanitaire
mais il y a quand même une dimension
géopolitique voilà et vous voyez si la
personne
accepte d'échanger et puis vous parlez
aussi un petit peu de tout sa famille
comment elle vit son parcours voilà
exactement un lien humain qui vous
permet de revoir cette personne et
ensuite d'échanger régulièrement avec
les progressivement vous voyez
l'intérêt de cette personne a dialoguer
et pour quelle raison alors ça peut
reposer sur de l'argent ça peut reposer
sur
le besoin de faire passer des messages à
travers ça sa communauté à travers voilà
ça perception pour son pays et ainsi de
suite et au bout d'un moment on peut
considérer qu'elle est recruter parce
qu'effectivement elle est consciente de
travailler pour un service étranger en
l'occurrence la DGSE et vous avez trouvé
une méthode qui peut être donc l'argent
ou là effectivement vous versez des
fonds vous aider la personne
voilà mais ça peut aussi se traduire par
des demande de visa pour la famille pour
les des visites médicales des opérations
parce que les gens ont pas de sécurité
sociale et donc ce que vous dites c'est
que cette personne là se cette source
que vous recrutez sur le terrain elle
sait forcément qu'elle l'est avec la
DGSE on a en tête souvent l'espion qui
prend des informations sans établir
finalement ce contact sans dire
directement qu'il est de tel ou tel
au départ vous ne le dites pas vous
restez sous votre couverture de
diplomate et c'est progressivement à
travers les questions que vous allez
vous livrer et dire finalement pour qui
la personne est censée travailler il
faut que la personne le sache pourquoi
parce que les sources appartiennent au
service donc on va pas leur faire croire
qu'ils travaillent pour Total ou pour
n'importe qui donc c'est pas possible il
faut absolument que la personne soit
consciente parce qu'en étant consciente
l'échange est quand même plus sincère si
c'est pour mentir et après raconter
n'importe quoi et après que la personne
s'aperçoive déjà à travers la
sensibilité des questions c'est faux
c'est donc c'est pas bon il faut
absolument au bout d'un moment révéler
votre appartement je pense que dans
l'imaginaire de pas mal de personnes il
y a la série du bureau des légendes
forcément qu'est-ce qui est juste ou pas
juste dans cette série telle qu'on voit
les agents de la DGSE alors l'histoire
est très très bien faite le scénario il
est vraiment génial parce que ça sur le
sur le fond c'est exactement ça après
sur la forme il y a plein de choses
effectivement qui ont été romancées par
exemple déclencher un téléphone à
distance c'est pas possible si vous
voulez faire des opérations comme ça
faut que vous ayez eu en main le
téléphone de la personne et que vous
ayez pu effectivement le piéger les
histoires d'agent déployées directement
au contact des djihadistes etc
c'est quand même un peu gros parce que
voilà là on est un peu dans dans le film
mais la
certaines méthodologie effectivement
sont respectées l'histoire de des
échanges par parfois Rome boîte mail ça
oui tout à fait ça moi je l'ai fait dans
votre livre vous parlez de WhatsApp vous
parlez de signal de pas mal de
plateformes il y a un élément
intéressant que vous dites c'est que
finalement la plus grande discrétion
c'est peut-être d'utiliser des services
qui sont relativement communs est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus
c'est un principe simple c'est de donner
le plus utilisé plus c'est noyé dans la
masse donc c'est beaucoup plus difficile
à remonter si vous prenez des
applications extrêmement sophistiquées
automatiquement pouvoir se poser la
question pour quelle raison voilà
aujourd'hui tout le monde utilise
WhatsApp donc si vous voulez
aller retrouver vos communications à
moins de posséder votre numéro c'est
très compliqué on va voir dans les
écoutes le flux entre tel numéro et tel
numéro mais on n'aura pas le contenu
quand vous avez une une source
relativement sensible et que vous ne
voulez pas utiliser le téléphone parce
qu'on peut imaginer que cette personne
soit surveillée vous n'avez pas encore
mis en place un véritable programme de
traitement donc ce forum c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal vous connectez ça peut
être n'importe quoi et effectivement
vous donner des informations qui
normalement correspondent à un prochain
lieu de rendez-vous de voyage vous
donner l'exemple de je vais être en
vacances aux Canaries le 15 février à
10h pour communiquer sur un lieu de
rendez-vous un endroit de façon plus ou
moins codée sur les forums les gens ils
changent par rapport à leurs vacances
par rapport à un tour opérateur leur
expérience donc vous pouvez facilement
lire tiens j'ai été je pars aux Canaries
la semaine prochaine
on va voir je vais suivre vos conseils
j'ai trouvé un vol pas cher tel jour à
telle heure et là vous avez des
nouvelles rendez-vous j'ai connu ce
métier là avec Internet et sans internet
qu'est-ce que ça a changé ce que ça a
changé le métier de d'agent sur le
terrain alors c'est énormément changé
parce que moi j'avais pas de téléphone
donc c'était un premier cabine
téléphonique
et sinon on avait un téléphone fixe au
bureau qui était détourné
détourné c'est-à-dire c'est un boîtier
que vous mettez chez quelqu'un et la
ligne est détournée chez cette personne
il y en a beaucoup qui
perdent du principe que avec le
téléphone avec Internet on fait tout à
distance mais c'est une grosse erreur
parce que c'est un métier lié à l'humain
si vous ne rencontrez pas les gens si
vous n'avez pas un échange de confiance
c'est pas possible est-ce que vous avez
des exemples d'erreurs à ne surtout pas
commettre nous avons en tête certaines
erreurs que vous avez pu faire ou de
personnes de collègues qui ont pu en
faire qui vous semblent importantes
quand on est rédacteur ou bien que vous
connaissez parfaitement un dossier bien
souvent la personne en face de vous
vous arrivez en savoir plus sur son pays
puis parce que vous avez regroupé toutes
les thématiques du pays vous connaissez
parfaitement les interlocuteurs voilà
lui il vous l'interrogez sur un domaine
de spécialité sur le reste il peut avoir
évidemment une connaissance c'est son
pays mais c'est plus une vue d'ensemble
en tant que Français si vous êtes
approché il y a des choses que vous ne
connaissez pas forcément l'histoire de
notre pays des détails c'est classiques
bah là c'est pareil donc c'est c'est
toute la difficulté c'est que certains
en posant des questions vont inonder la
personne de leur savoir et finalement
ils vont pas lui poser véritablement de
questions vont chercher à obtenir
confirmation de ce qu'il pense donc
l'autre effectivement un peu perdu va
dire oui
ou bien motiver par le gain va dire oui
et c'est là que vous fausser
complètement l'entretien vous avez
utilisé le mode manipulation de trois
fois si une forme de manipulation pour y
arriver quelle forme ça prend quand on
approche une source et comment est-ce
qu'on fait vous devez passer forcément
par une phase de manipulation parce que
la personne qui en face de vous elle va
défendre sa vision la vision de son pays
donc vous devez effectivement rentrer
dans le jeu et dire effectivement vous
avez raison
donner des exemples et c'est ça la
manipulation c'est ce maître
véritablement à la portée de votre
interlocuteur en épousant ces thèses
mais pas avec un simple oui c'est
effectivement en essayant d'étayer les
mêmes propos de sorte qu'elle comprenne
et qu'elle soit sensible à vos arguments
qui sont les mêmes et ça va l'encourager
à travailler dans ce domaine voilà c'est
ça quand vous voulez un filtrer un
mouvement ou autre faut épouser les
convictions de la personne à contrario
cette personne ça peut être vraiment la
dernière des pointures en assassin etc
ce que vous voulez mais là aussi il faut
développer un discours qui va
effectivement un peu dans le sens de la
personne et vous n'avez pas le choix
vous êtes obligé qu'il y a des choses
très sensibles vous pouvez pas vous
permettre de vous afficher avec au bout
d'un moment parce que c'est une personne
qui ne peut pas forcément assumer un
contact régulier avec vous donc ça sera
une relation qui peut être attachante
mais qui va rester dans un cas très
professionnel après vous en avez
d'autres qui peuvent assumer un contact
régulier et vous pouvez avoir une espèce
d'amitié naissante mais il faut toujours
garder en tête le principe c'est qu'une
source elle doit être transmissible une
fois que vous partez vous avez terminé
votre mandat
il faut la transmettre à votre
successeur sinon c'est pas une source si
elle est pas transmissible si elle est
uniquement attachée à vous ce n'est pas
une source du service c'est un copain et
là ça va plus voilà pour parler
notamment des histoires de jaune d'œuf
que vous avez dû avaler avant de
rejoindre une source est-ce que vous
voulez nous raconter cette histoire là
oui ça s'est produit lorsque j'avais été
au contact de l'un des traducteurs de
Poutine donc il y avait été ciblé le but
était effectivement de le recruter ça se
passait plutôt bien
dans quel pays c'était à Paris il
faisait son stagiat
à Paris et donc
évidemment il buvait beaucoup
le problème c'est quoi au bout d'un
moment je pouvais pas sans arrêt lui
verser à boire et donc fallait que je
boive aussi et donc la technique on
m'avait dit retard pour retarder
l'absorption d'alcool et jaune donc
c'est ce que je faisais à la chambre
d'hôtel avant donc je
je battais trois quatre jaunes d'oeuf et
puis Glou je les avalaient pour que ça
reste fixé un temps et ça marche ça
marche ça vous empêche pas de Bourg
après mais ça décale dans le temps
puisque l'absorption se fait plus
lentement qu'est-ce que vous avez le
droit de dire ou ne pas dire quand vous
êtes agent de la DGSE au niveau de la
famille tout le monde le savait puisque
c'était un peu une histoire de famille
alors voilà mais finalement en fait vous
n'en parlez pas parce que moi mon épouse
travaillais là aussi s'il fallait qu'on
passe notre temps après arriver à la
maison à part alors là c'est une vie si
oui
donc finalement on en parlait pas et
puis tous les couples sont davantage
d'accaparés quand vous rentrez le soir
vous avez les enfants et ce qui peut
être problème familiaux la scolarité etc
donc vous avez autre chose à faire que
dire bah tiens j'ai participé à tes
opérations etc souvent ça se limitait à
oui un tel d'un tel ce chef pénible
exactement et par rapport à moi il y a
des trucs ma femme elle découvre dans le
bouquin au bout de 40 ans
quels sont les consignes qui sont
données par la DGSE est-ce que si vous
êtes marié la personne avec qui vous
êtes marié a le droit de savoir ce que
vous faites ou pas bien évidemment oui
oui vous pouvez dire aujourd'hui que
vous faites partie de la GSM mais vous
ne pouvez pas développer exactement
votre activité et tout ce qui touche
effectivement secret défense ça vous
pouvez pas c'est évident maintenant
quelqu'un qui est marié s'il a envie de
se confier à son épouse et c'est son
droit
juridiquement pas la tailler ils sont
ils sont mariés l'impression parfois
dans le cadre de votre mission de faire
certaines choses qui n'étaient pas
éthiques selon vous oui bien sûr
quand vous êtes au contact de criminel
etc et vous êtes vous êtes obligé de
protéger
protéger dans quel cadre protéger parce
que c'est une source protégée par
protéger parce que c'est une source elle
vous donne des renseignements
donc le problème c'est que si vous jouez
sur une moralité permanente au bout du
compte vous verrez personne
faut accepter ça il me semble que vous
en parlez dans le dans le livre parler
du boucher de Power en Centrafrique
notamment vous voulez nous en parler un
petit peu le boucher power pourquoi
parce que c'est une ville qui est au
nord de la Centrafrique vers le Tchad et
Cameroun et avec ses troupes la garde
républicaine et il avait lancé comme
c'était un lieu de rébellion il est
massacré des villages entiers femmes
enfants tout le monde y est passé il
avait massacré 1500 personnes même le
président bodysisée était assez choqué
moi j'en avais parlé mais il a pris un
hélicoptère il est revenu il était assez
décontenancé mais l'autre était
complètement givrée et bah oui mais moi
j'en avais besoin c'était le patron de
la viande républicaine et je pouvais pas
lui dire c'est pas bien on va te mettre
en prison je peux pas faire ça donc
j'avais besoin aussi de renseignements
qu'il était capable de me fournir parce
que c'est un type qui avait un ego
démesuré il avait pas besoin d'argent
donc j'étais obligé d'être à son contact
même si c'était pas une source qu'est-ce
qui intéresse a DGSE en général quand on
va sur le terrain récupérer des infos
très souvent c'est du politique au
sécurité
c'est tout ce qui concourt aux individus
aux personnes proches du pouvoir et qui
vont développer certains secteurs
d'activité et qui vont nous être
favorables ou non tout ce qui aura été
transmis à Paris par ses postes
extérieurs
donc vous informations elles sont donc
compilées côté
et la note qui va être produite va
permettre d'aider à la décision
un ménis le chef de l'État par rapport
aux liens qu'ils doivent fixer par
exemple il va rencontrer prochainement
son homologue je sais pas j'invente
tunisien algérien ou autre l'Élysée va
demander ça va redescendre par le
conseiller Afrique va demander une fiche
une fiche complète sur la situation du
pays où tel ministre qu'il est voilà
donc ça ça permet aussi de s'adapter à
son interlocuteur mais ça permet aussi
d'avoir des éléments qui vont aider dans
la discussion un ministre chef d'État en
général qui voulaient c'est très
important est-ce qu'il y a des
différences majeures entre les services
de renseignement français et les
services de l'enseignement américain par
exemple quelle différence c'est ce qu'on
voit entre les deux types d'agents par
définition la culture américaine ne se
prête pas beaucoup
enfin mon sens des échanges très très
humains tel qu'on l'entend nous en
Europe bref ils ont tous misé sur la
technique au niveau des gens que j'ai
côtoyé donc de mes homologues américains
ils préfèrent ils savaient qu'on se
débrouillait beaucoup mieux pour faire
de la recherche humaine nous c'est notre
ADN c'est notre point fort eux en fait
leur terrain c'est
je vais recruté il a de l'argent c'est
tout mais c'est plus compliqué que ça
c'est pas le même de relation quasiment
de marchand de tapis avec certaines
sources dire on veut une info on vous
donne l'argent
quitte à ne nouer du coup de de liens
humains ou de contact en gros on vient
vous voir
ils se disent bon celui-là il est
ministre il gagne à peu près temps bon
il y a les écoutes tout on sait qu'il a
traitait le transfert d'argent en gros
voilà son patrimoine ils viennent
vladent 200000 euros par exemple je veux
ça alors ça va marcher une fois sur mais
ça marche ça marche prenez n'importe qui
chacun a un prix de toute façon faut
comprendre ça donc ça marche mais ça
rime à quoi rien puisque c'est pas une
personne avec laquelle vous allez
entretenir sur la durée une relation
voilà une chose
c'est peut-être suffisant selon eux pour
arriver à entretenir ce lien parce que
je sais même pas si le lieu les
intéresse en fait ce qu'ils intéresse
c'est à un moment donné une personne
détient certaines informations donc je
vais mettre du paquet de frites sur la
table pour obtenir ça et et après tant
pis on se reverra plus est-ce qu'on va
partir du principe que tous les pays
s'espionnent entre eux y compris nos
alliés les plus proches tout le monde
espionne tout le monde c'est logique le
problème c'est qu'avec nos alliés les
plus proches américains britanniques
allemands etc on ne va pas s'espionner
ce ne sont pas des cibles
mais en revanche sur certains segments
ou nos intérêts peuvent être mis en jeu
là effectivement il y aura une notion
d'espionnage nous on l'a fait aux
États-Unis sur certains sujets eux le
font également sur nous c'est évident
voilà mais ça ne va pas être un pays
désigné comme cible ça va pas être
chinois Russie machin etc voilà c'est
totalement différent est-ce que vous
avez le droit de dire non à la DGSE sur
certaines missions est-ce que vous êtes
envoyé vous suivez vous suivez les
règles
on va dire non vous recevez des
orientations qui correspondent donc au
segment sur lequel vous devez travailler
si vous voulez pas le faire ou si vous
dites il est pas bien ça l'assassin ou
un thème faut changer de métier c'est
pas possible c'est pas possible
autrement c'est la défense des intérêts
de la France tel qu'ils sont dictées par
la DGSE avec avec des consignes précises
et ça vous avez eu des quatre
consciences où vous avez le sentiment
que la mission qu'on vous donnez n'était
pas
éthique ou juste quand bien même elle
était elle était donnée
parce que
dans les domaines sur lesquels j'y
travaillais ça correspondait à la
défense des intérêts et français voilà
après
vous retrouvez à travailler avec des
pays contre des pays c'est pas
nécessairement contre leur économie
donc moi il y a des fois
non franchement j'ai pas eu ce problème
là et même avec des hauts responsables
africains des fois ils me disait ce que
tu fais c'est normal tu défends ton pays
et il me disait ben moi je défends le
mien aussi voilà c'est clair et on a
parlé d'évolution technologique on a
parlé on a compris de du rôle de la
France à l'international etc comment
est-ce que vous voyez cette évolution du
renseignement français évolution du
renseignement français ça passe
maintenant de plus en plus par des
échanges avec des services étrangers
partenaires étrangers parce que de plus
en plus on travaille sur des
environnements sous régionaux des
grandes problématiques si on prend le
cas de l'Ukraine il y a forcément une
coalition
d'intérêt lorsque vous avez le
développement de la politique de la
Chine effectivement cette puissance
économique
là aussi faut conjuguer tous les efforts
voilà après l'islamisme le terrorisme
aussi et il y a des états sur lesquels
nous sommes obligés de nous appuyer la
Turquie par exemple très très bien avec
la Turquie c'est des fois on a une
mauvaise rapport avec certains pays mais
au niveau des services publiquement
entre la Turquie et la France et les
dernières années
on a parlé de mon monde peur de mon plus
difficile
votre meilleur souvenir qu'elle forme ce
qu'il a pu prendre alors le meilleur
souvenir c'était
à Djibouti avec l'arrestation de Peter
shérif les liens d'amitié avec les
officiers djiboutiens que je pilotais
formé etc c'était vraiment une qui a été
petite pour donner un peu de contexte
rang du Jihad c'est quelqu'un qui avait
rejoint
dash en Irak très rapidement dans les
années 2000 puis en Syrie
capturé par les Américains extradés en
France placé en détention provisoire
avant son procès il fuit il arrive à
s'échapper il rejoint Yémen et c'est là
que ça traque commence pour nous c'était
un type extrêmement important parce que
manifestement il a été l'un des
commanditaires de des attentats de
Charlie Hebdo ou la justice on va
essayer de le prouver puisqu'il est
envoyé aux assises donc pour moi c'est
un un très grand souvenir merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté de prendre le temps
c'est super intéressant